alors maintenant on en vient à scènes de
ménages s'était effectivement écrit
juste en face de moi suite à la
polémique née autour de anne elisabeth
blateau qui a dérapé à une forme un peu
arrosée elle s'en est pris à un mécène
des conséquences sur la série scènes de
ménages on vous a fait un petit récap on
en parle juste après c'est une publicité
dont m6 se serait sans doute bien passé
anne elisabeth blateau l'une des têtes
d'affiché de scènes de ménages l'un des
programmes de la chaîne est poursuivi
par la justice pour avoir agressé le 6
septembre dernier une femme pompier à
son domicile
c'est pas possible c'est une blague
malheureusement non selon les
informations de la police la crise
aurait tenté d'étrangler un jeune
pompier et passera devant le tribunal en
correctionnelle en 2020 je m'y attendais
pas
anne elisabeth blateau non plus elle a
même publié de sincères excuses sur ces
réseaux le lendemain de l'agression
j'ai eu un comportement inacceptable à
l'encontre de plusieurs personnes dont
des pompiers venus pour m'aider je leur
adresse à toutes mes plus plates et
sincères excuses
j'ai honte de n'avoir été que l'ombre de
moi même honte d'avoir une attitude
excécrable tu peux arrêter de poster des
trucs sur un stade reste à savoir
comment va réagir la chaîne si elle est
condamnée
cette erreur pourrait coûter très cher à
l'actrice alors selon vous anne
elisabeth blateau at elle encore sa
place dans scènes de ménages
alors la question est elle encore sa
place dans scènes de ménages les
pancartes oui non merci beaucoup à mr en
carton c'est pas grave pour vous c'est
pas grave mais non alors non à vous de
gamme en question est est ce que je
trouve qu'il faut être exemplaire
aujourd'hui dans mon existence je peux
dire quand même dans un contexte de
révoltes contre ceux qui viennent nous
sauver la vie ponctuellement et peut
être retirée de l'antenne
voilà c'est ce que libération c'est pas
excusable n'y a pas de problème
maintenant c'est un être humain
tout le monde doit faire des erreurs est
ce que j'apprécie c'est qu'elle s'est
excusé elle a reconnu l a pas fait voilà
final faire la sourde oreille
la fumée lassouts dorel a soulevé trouve
que c'est rare aujourd'hui d'avoir des
artistes qui font des conneries mais
qu'il les assume à 100 % et je trouve
que bah c'est pas mal quand même
alors moi je pense à laquelle on a eu un
non c'est pas possible
vous êtes un personnage public donc vous
devez non pas être exemplaire mais au
moins faire preuve d'une attitude
respectable
lassé par n'est pas dans la vie privée
d'une erreur personnelle on est dans
quelque chose qui effectivement comme
disait christine un jury mme mais met en
péril des gens des pompiers qui sont en
ce moment l'objet de jets de
caillassages algues dans des cités où
ils vont préparer donc si les
personnages publics font ça d'autres
peuvent le faire donc la mélasse mais
elle a fait amende honorable à s'excuser
elle n'avait pas fermé la sanction c'est
ça elle ne doit plus apparaître dans la
série à risque
excuse moi j'y viens mais elle veut être
elle va être jugé sauf qu'à un moment
donné il ya une justice qui est là pour
ça qui sommes nous nous on est les juges
et elle va être retirée de l'antenne je
suis désolé il ya des politiques qui
font bien pire et on sait et alors même
nom mais je veux dire à un moment faut
arrêter on a l'impression que maintenant
on est dans une société où on ne peut
plus rien faire elle s'excuse et c'est
grave ce qu'elle aime ça c'est sûr mais
le fait de juger du préfet qui pour dire
que c'est pas la meilleure mais c'est
vrai que les pompiers c'est pas la
meilleure des six oui
je vais donc c'est pas un bar du coin
juste conséquent pour réduire ce taux
n'est par les coaches parce que au
lendemain de la sphère l'audience à a
perdu à peu près 300 mille
téléspectateurs pendant 2 3 jours puis
est remonté aujourd'hui sa porte plutôt
bien avec près de 4 millions de
téléspectateurs ça reste une valeur sûre
de m6 oui d'ailleurs fête ses 10 ans
cette année la série la série web est
bien vrai ça reste une série chorale
quand même il ya cinq couples dix
comédiens tout repose pas sur elle est
ce que est ce que les comédiens pas une
question qui est encore une question
bête je ne sais pas est ce que les
comédiens sont pas plus excusable que
les animateurs télé par exemple c'est un
comédien on connaît ses 70 ans il s'est
plu non mais je pose des questions et
excuses personne n'est excusable
il faut se tenir maintenant il faut pas
exagérer non plus on n'est pas la police
et la police de dèche
quand même la gueule un soir elle a
dérapé et s'est excusé l'histoire c'est
ça c'est moi je prends comme ça
personnellement je me cale est parti en
soir dans un bar à l'appui coller avec
des copains et des ailes à l'abus
d'alcool est dangereux on le dit les
pompiers sont arrivés à la déraper elle
s'est excusée maintenant en france
jusqu'à là dit il va y avoir un jugement
ce jugement j'aimerais bien qu'on en
parle
j'aimerais bien qu'on lequel une
sanction les gens même une sanction
financière pourquoi pas quelques idoles
qui donne des dommages intérêts à ses
pompiers qui sont venus là et puis comme
on l'a dit là c'est donc au ministre on
pardonne moi gérante est notre notre
ministre qui en pleine nuit était
complètement déjanté que des mojitos
plein la tête en et d'attentats un
samedi deux personnes
non non j'en ai rien à [ __ ] mon
ministre que je paye s'il est ici un
devoir d'exemple d'exemplarité autant
que les pompiers qu'il faut respecter
comme gilles l'adie qui se font
caillasser
quand appelle les pompiers viennent te
sauver la vie ils donnent leur vie pour
toi
donc tu dois les respecter
qu'est ce à dire ces professions
je serai victoire je serai vite pompiers
militaires parce que j'ai pas ce qu'il
faut dans le sable pour aller dans un
peu sauvé des gens ces gens là il faut
les respecter mais je vais aussi voir
les ministres et compagnie images
montrent l'exemple ya quelque chose
commence alors la télévision faut pas
oublier que c'est une fréquence qui est
donnée par l'état en échange de graisse
de choses à respecter une charte de
valeurs de charte à respecter une
convention qu'on a justement avec l'état
je suis désolé lorsque mais souvent des
animateurs télé en grand les met à pied
à l'antenne parce qu'ils ont fait des
erreurs moi je dis ponctuellement will
humain pour les mains un exemplaire bien
sûr mais tout le monde est unanime à
douarnenez elle affirmé m comme m qu'on
me mette arrive à une sanction mais une
sanction mais on a quand même un devoir
d'exemple à lens
moi j'ai une cold wave c'est la vie la
clause qui m'oblige à bien me comporter
dans la vie y compris dans la vie privée
ça que si demain matin j'ai importe quoi
on nous voit est vraiment dans un bar à
insulter tout le monde la chaîne et elle
ne peut bien évidemment ils vont ils ont
doit le très bien c'est très bien parce
que par rapport à ton coin excuse moi
jle par rapport à ton contrat ton
contrat c'est pas un contrat à 1300
euros on va pas se mentir c'est pas le
smic donc c'est normal qu'on te mettre
une clause en disant tu auras une image
temps le suédois c'était d'accord a
représenté quelque chose et ont surtout
on a besoin de toi le vendredi pour
faire l'émission il s'agit pact arim en
garde à vue jeudi soir
[Applaudissements]
je vous rassure sébastien dans le mur